le procès de patrick dils et après le
témoignage hier devant la cour d'assises
du rhône des experts psychiatres qui ont
vu en lui un homme normal c'est
aujourd'hui au tour de ses parents de se
rendre à la barre sur place stéphanie
perez et jérémie drieu les parents de
patrick dils témoignent en premier
fatiguée nerveusement après 15 ans de
bataille ils savent qu'ils jouent leur
dernière chance il est innocent s'il
était coupable je me serais suicidé je
n'aurais pas supporté d'avoir engendré
un monstre dit jacqueline deal
malgré la tension la famille 10 me
croire à une issue favorable à ce
troisième procès est la troisième procès
mais c'est celui pour nous est le mieux
et le plus juste pour nous parce qu'elle
a vraiment la présidente elle interroge
vraiment tout le monde elle va au fond
des affaires et le s'attarde pas sur les
détails dont je suis confiante
j'avais été éprouvant mais bon je me
tape a pas séduit
la pet shop
les familles des deux petits garçons en
riffs plus discrètement
elle ne parle plus aux deals elle reste
convaincue de la culpabilité de patrick
et rejette l'hypothèse faune très
éprouvé les mamans et les grands-mères
ont déjà quitté l'audience à plusieurs
reprises ces deux dernières semaines
c'est très très dur à vivre de
réentendre
le déroulement des faits la manière dont
ces enfants ont été massacrées dans des
conditions atroces et également les
dénégations de qu'une personne que la
justice de leur payant qu'ils ont
confiance leur avait livré on l'avait
désigné comme coupable il ya 14 ans
quatorze ans plus tard on leur dit ça
n'est peut-être pas le coupable est à la
suite du procès de reims on a eu
confirmation que c'était bien le
coupable
ils ont cent pour les siens coupable
pour les familles des enfants chaque
jour la balance a penché d'un côté puis
de l'autre
cette deuxième semaine qui s'achève n'a
pas permis d'éclaircir le mystère de
montigny-lès-metz le verdict très
attendu sera rendue le mercredi prochain